do you find it more difficult the older
you get maybe this is a stupid question
to remember lines to uh just acting in
general
it's my fear the confidence i lose a
word
for something an important word i can't
i can't remember it or or something will
go blank
i mean it just i mean i remember when i
was in my 20s or early 30s
learning a script over the weekend so i
could replace somebody
uh and i and i just went blind page by
page by page
put it in my head never had to go over
it again
i just knew it and and and i
i have trouble uh keeping the lines in
my head now
yeah and and as soon as i start i think
okay you can do this you can do this but
there's
that thing of am i gonna humiliate
myself
because it is it's humiliating for me
because i used to be able to just
read it and know it like you do like you
used to
i like i used to it's harder now though
isn't it
i'll be i'll be 49 in july yeah
it is hard it's always been for me i've
had to go over it and over and over and
over and over just
so i have the confidence to be because i
used to watch you on the airplane on the
way back on the weekends you know when
you went
we'd race for the let's see we've got
the up front seats yeah
yeah but i remember you'd start learning
them then
and i would i would kind of wait and
yeah i think my fear is that i don't
want
to i want to be so prepared that i just
want the lines to be second nature that
i feel like
if that's how i tried to get them too
but it but but the first episode that i
did
uh i thought i could do it better than i
thought so i i i
i i i the next script i had to spend
much more time and
start immediately as i got it just to
start sticking it in my head
because a a four-week rehearsal doing a
play
will get it there i've found you know
it's
it's harder i mean i used to be able
just to know it
like on day one or two or something
i there were times when i don't even
remember having to sit down and learn
the lines
they just i did it enough that i just
knew it
do you still want to do plays do you
still want it yes oh my god
that's the easy part because you do have
that rehearsal
which which lets it get in there because
there's
there's something about starting with
with you think am i going to make it
through this big speech
as soon as that little thing of am i
it's like a flinch happens and you think
and you tense up
we had a great scoop script supervisor
marjorie
and i'd work and i'd work and i'd
it up and it up and come back
and then about the like the third or
fourth take it would just go
and she'd come over and i'd been through
such agony and she said
or you can do it like that every time if
you want
[Laughter]
she had such a good humor about it
because i actually understood i think
and that was on fear the walking dead
yeah yeah yeah
i mean it was i felt alive again because
i thought
god what's gonna happen are we gonna
ever work again but
but this the kind of weird part about it
was
that everybody's masked everybody that
makes me nervous actors are hearst
masked
and so you can't really you know see
what everybody's doing because you can't
see they're
all you see there's eyes and not hear
them real well because they're a little
muffled
and i'm also getting i think a little it
maybe got the wax
too much wax in my ears i don't know and
after lunch once i thought we were
moving on to another scene
and we redid the whole scene that we've
done all morning
and i i just i i like went haywire
and thought i can't do it i know it's
already gone from my head
so i made it terrible so i i'm
learning through through each time but i
i it felt so good to be back at work
because i thought when is this going to
happen again and the theater stuff is
even
i mean that's going to be take longer
you